leave motivation watch your top ten hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so get ready to hustle and
show your success and delegate your
weaknesses with Sara Blakely and my take
on her top ten rules a success volume 5
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with real number
one hustle I feel like hustle is the
willingness to work really really hard
and then also your willingness to get
the job done like kind of navigating and
doing what it takes and and so I yeah
I've there's so much about my journey
where I was like I am NOT gonna let the
outcome or my success be contingent on
other people as much as I can control it
help it navigate it I'm going to so so
yeah in the beginning especially still
now I mean obviously I'm hustling I'm
like at this where I am now and I'm
running around the airport asking people
to follow me on Instagram you know I
just feel like it's innate in me also to
a degree but the in the beginning it's
like there's a few examples that come to
mind you mentioned that I paid my I
called my friends and asked them to go
buy Spanx and I wrote to everybody
checks and sent them a check because I
needed to drive momentum and I had no
money to advertise so I'm like this
product is gonna sit on the shelves so I
needed to get people to go in and buy it
I also when I went into the stores I
realized very quickly that my product
was in the sleepiest part of the
department store it was back in the
corner and nobody was going there so
then I immediately went to a Target and
I bought envelope dividing dividers that
you put on your home death and I ran
around Neiman Marcus and put them at
every register and I put
banks in them and then I walked away and
Neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and and I did that
because I had to get my product out of
the department and because I did that
women in shoes started buying Spanx and
women in contemporary and and those
decisions made such a big difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it because I
you know everybody thought somebody else
approved it it was so successful that
the head of Neiman's was like whatever
this girl's doing let her keep doing it
rule number two ensure your success I
cold called Neiman's Saks Nordstrom
Bloomingdale's QVC I was out on the road
and I think a lot of entrepreneurs make
the mistake they think once you get the
order you're golden and that couldn't be
any farther from the truth
once you get the order that's when the
real work starts I was absolutely
determined to ensure my own success and
I think that's what it takes I didn't
want my success to be contingent on
anyone else having to sell this so I hit
the ground running and I went from
department store to department store and
I would do mourning rallies at the store
where I would gather people around well
the store manager said Serena you can do
it with the hosiery associates well I'd
travel all the way to Arizona and
there'd be three hosiery associates so I
quickly was like I got to get the whole
store this morning rally so I would go
into the entrance before the store open
like a Neiman's or a Saks or a
Bloomingdale's and I would run around
and introduce myself to every employees
setting up their station and I'd say hi
I'm Sarah and I would try to convince
them that it would be worth their time
to come see my morning meeting and I got
everybody there I had taken the Oprah
clip and the little bit of local press
side I'd received and put it on a video
and did that in my morning rally and it
was such an important thing that I was
doing I inadvertently was building a
sales force that wasn't on my payroll
and they all across the country became
my biggest advocates for the product and
started selling it on behalf of Spanx in
me rule number three delegate your
weaknesses what's the best advice that
you've received someone told me that
what you delegate is 80% as good as you
would have done it yourself let it go
I took inventory of what am I good at
what am I not good at what do I you know
enjoy and don't enjoy they're usually
the same thing ironically like I was
very clear in the first year I was not
good at shipping and handling and I
wasn't good at you know so many
different things about managing the
inventory but I loved inventing the next
idea I loved the brand I loved the way
that I was communicating with consumers
so being able to free yourself up to do
what you do best and let the people who
do the other aspects do s do it via
number 4 don't be afraid to fail and I
think companies if you can create a
culture where they're not terrified to
fail or make a mistake then you're gonna
you're gonna be a highly productive and
more innovative culture so having people
feel free to laugh at themselves and
watching me as their leader laugh at
myself I have oops meetings at spanks
where we get up and I tell them what I
messed up at or a mistake that I made
and I usually tell a funny story about
it and I encourage everybody else in the
company to stand up and say that and
then share and make it a funny story and
so I think that that helps also if you
want to learn from other successful
women entrepreneurs' checking my 2:54
girlboss it's free the link to join is
in the description below when I was
selling copiers door-to-door I had a
very clear vision of what my life was
gonna be like from day one I just I
never tried to hide that I was the girl
in my apartment with the red backpack
rule number five be resourceful when
Spanx started I got to set the stage a
little bit for you there were no self
there were no excuse me blackberries no
one had ever heard of an iPhone or an
iPod before I mean the Kardashians were
in like the fifth grade
and MapQuest was just getting started so
half the time I was on my computer in
the hotel that I was staying at and
trying to MapQuest my next location and
it was a really crazy time as I'm
driving all around I you know I'm
thinking to myself actually I remember
this one time in Chicago I had spent so
much time alone on the road I did an
event at the Neiman Marcus outside of
Evanston I believe it was at in oak
brook or Northbrook and I spent the
whole day promoting lifting up my pant
leg and turning and shaking my butt for
everyone in the entrance and that's you
know I'd been setting up these tables
and moving them farther and farther out
of the hosiery Department to the point
where they were in the entrance of
Neiman Marcus I mean people would walk
and I go hi I'm Sarah and I would flash
them my bud and you know I was trying
everything I put Donuts on the table I
was like have a doughnut and some Spanx
rule number six be persistent every time
I heard a no I would just keep going
once she finally got a yes came the
first self the very first place I called
was Neiman Marcus and I just kept
calling the buyer on the phone until she
picked up I just said I'm Sara Blakely I
invented a product that is going to
change the way your customers wear
clothes please give me 15 minutes of
your time and I said I will fly to
Dallas and she said if you're willing to
fly here I will give you 15 minutes so I
booked a flight and halfway through
telling her about the product I mean
everything about her was perfect right
her belt matched her pen that matched
her shoes I was highly intimidated
sitting there with my my old backpack
and I said you know what I think you
just need to come with me to the
bathroom when she mid pitch and she went
excuse me and I said yes just just come
with me to the bathroom I'm gonna show
you what my product can do first hand
rule number seven take control of your
life a lot of people think that Spanx
started when I cut the feet out of my
pantyhose but actually it started long
before that it started when I was
selling fax machines door-to-door and
getting my cart business card ripped up
in my face being escorted out of
buildings all day every day that I woke
up one day and just thought I'm in the
wrong movie like how did this happen
this is not my life cut scene director
like called the producer and I got out a
piece of paper and I wrote down what am
I good at
and the only thing in the good column
was sales and I thought okay what am I
gonna do with that and I ended up
writing in my journal I'm going to
invent a product and sell it to millions
of people that will make them feel good
and then I asked the universe for an
idea and I was very specific and it took
two years and I only cut the feet out of
my pantyhose one time and I was not
gonna squander any idea the universe
gave me because I hadn't really asked
for it and then the minute I cut the
feet out I started trying to make it I
started looking up old manufacturers on
the internet this is before Ali Baba
wasn't it yes rule number eight
differentiate yourself I've got to
differentiate yourself I always ask
myself why am i different how am i
different and I think it's very
important to be I call them the three
C's but clear concise and confident you
have to be able to describe it in a
minute or less make it so clear the
customer really wants to make smart
decisions and they really want us to
make it easy for them so I always say
make somebody feel the pain or if it's
not the pain which means the problem on
why you did what you did or why you're
creating what you create then explain to
them your uniqueness and then right
after that you've got to give them the
solution very quickly and then take it
through and say why you're the best I
mean very quickly explain to them in
just a few seconds why you're the best
option and I find that very very helpful
so in everything I do ask myself why am
i different rule number nine deal with
rejections I call myself a girl who
really likes to challenge herself to do
things that scare her to auditioning at
Disney World
I ended up at Disney World because I
failed the LSAT and I felt very sad that
I most likely wasn't gonna be heading
off to law school I am a terrible test
taker so I did what my parents said of
course would be the most natural thing
to do and I got in my car and drove to
Disney World and tried out to be goofy
and just to add you know insult to
injury I'm too short to be goofy so I
just failed the LSAT I went through all
the auditions to become a character and
you have to be 5/8 to be goofy and I'm
5/6 so I'm the height of a chipmunk yes
so they wanted to make me a chipmunk I
drool number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is just be who
you are what keeps you so unbelievably
grounded amid all your resounding
success I I feel like success just makes
you more of who you already were I feel
like money and success just does that so
it's like it holds a magnifying glass up
to who you are
people you know people always ask you
that and I'm like I don't know who else
to be I mean I am Who I am so the money
the success and so I like to say if you
were a jerk before you got really
successful and a lot of money usually
become a bigger jerk usually and if you
were insecure you'll become more
insecure if you were nice you become
nicer if you were generous you become
more generous it's literally just a
magnifying glass now I have a special
bonus clip from Sarah on how to help
others that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point lightning questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go
question number one where do you need to
just be more of who you are number two
what's the rejection that you need to
deal with and move past and number three
what is the weakness that you need to
start delegating and if you promise to
take action after watching this video we
don't just watch videos anymore we do
something after watching them give me a
hashtag believe down in the comments
make that promise to yourself and then
get
as long as I could remember I felt very
compelled to help women and I have had
such extreme gratitude from an early age
on being a woman born in America I've
been very acutely aware that I was born
at the right time in the right place in
the right country and I would love to
ensure that I can use my life and my
success to help other women have the
same opportunity and then also help you
know women everywhere to fulfill their
best potential because I think the world
needs it
if you want more Sara Blakely check out
the last top-10 I did on her the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I wanted to be a lawyer and I'm a
terrible test taker after I basically
bombed the LSAT
I hate tried out at Disney World to be
goofy